Précédemment dans Chroniques de Prof.
Des ermites barbus ont pris le contrôle du
monde.
Ils étaient seuls dans le désert, et ils
ont maintenant des bâtiments.
Ils font du fromage.
Ils éduquent vos enfants.
Il ne me reste que 24 minutes pour venir à
bout de leur histoire.
Bonjour et bienvenue dans «Les Moines:
Evolution», qui est la suite de «Les
Moines: Origins», si vous l'aviez manquée
je vous conseille de la regarder parce que
c'était bien.
La dernière fois on a expliqué l'origine
des moines jusqu'au Xe siècle et on va maintenant
aborder leur évolution.
-Eh c'est plutôt clair comme explications!
Dans la dernière vidéo on était arrivés
au IXe siècle, où les abbayes étaient devenues
à la fois des centres religieux, des exploitations
agricoles et des seigneuries.
Les carolingiens en avaient fondé un sacré
paquet et elles étaient désormais unifiées
sous la règle bénédictine, jusqu'aux invasions
vikings qui avaient un peu freiné les choses.
Certains moines s'enfuient alors en emportant
reliques et manuscrits avec eux, et parfois
les vendent au passage...
Le monachisme était aussi affaibli à cause
de quelques scandales de l’Église comme
le nicolaïsme.
-Des clercs qui ont prononcé leurs vœux
mais qui font quand même la chose! C'est
quoi la chose?
-Tu es trop jeune.
-Et en plus les rois ou princes qui avaient
fondé des abbayes commençaient de plus en
plus à s'y croire chez eux, ils nommaient
eux-même les abbés parmi les copains, parfois
même des laïcs qui ne s'installaient même
pas au monastère mais en touchaient les revenus,
par contre, faut pas déconner.
Les abbés devaient payer une troupe si le
roi décidait de convoquer l'ost, l'armée,
pas la série à rallonge, et accompagner
ces troupes bien que le MMA ou toute autre
forme de combat ne soit pas leur spécialité.
En réaction à tout ça, au Xe siècle les
abbayes cherchent de plus à se coaliser et
à obtenir au passage quelques privilèges
royaux ou mieux: papaux!
-Chapeau.
-C'est donc maintenant le moment de parler
de Cluny, monastère bourguignon fondé vers
910 par le duc Guillaume d'Aquitaine et mis
sous la protection de saint Pierre.
Et qui donc est le successeur de saint Pierre
en terme d'autorité?
-Le pape!
-Donc Cluny se place direct sous l'autorité
du pape en snobant totalement les évêques
qui se trouvent entre les deux, ce qui lui
permet d'obtenir quelques avantages de ce
dernier.
En 932, le pape Jean XI confirme l'exemption
de l'abbaye de toute autorité autre que la
sienne contre le paiement de dix sous d'or
tous les cinq ans.
Plus encore, le pape interdit d'excommunier
tout moine de Cluny et donne aux abbés de
Cluny le pouvoir de réformer toutes les abbayes
qui le demandent et qui deviennent alors rattachées
à Cluny.
-J'ai pas compris.
-Imagine que tu es un petit monastère admiratif
de Cluny et qui voudrait rejoindre son clan.
-Je suis un petit monastère admiratif de
Cluny, je voudrais rejoindre son clan.
-TA REFORME, C'EST MAINTENANT.
-Du coup les abbés de Cluny sont tout le
temps sur les routes pour réformer toutes
celles qui le demandent.
En 1049 Cluny a ainsi 40 petites sœurs en
Europe, mais passe à 1450 à la fin du XIe
siècle.
Efficace.
Chaque abbaye affiliée ou prieuré reste
sujette à l'archi-abbé, le boss de Cluny,
tellement puissant qu'il rend jaloux les évêques
et les autres abbés ce qui fait que certaines
abbayes décident de reprendre leur indépendance
par la suite.
Chaque monastère est à la tête de seigneuries,
c'est l'opulence.
La particularité de Cluny est de développer
très fort la liturgie au point d'en faire
l'activité principale des moines, le travail
manuel devient relégué aux frères convers
qu'on verra par la suite, ou à des serfs
ou salariés de l'abbaye.
Même la retraite et la méditation des moines
passe au second plan, ils peuvent chanter
jusque 150 psaumes par jour.
Pour compenser ils améliorent un peu leur
alimentation, comme je l'avais déjà dit
dans ma vidéo sur l'alimentation au MA, et
s'autorisent même à boire du vin.
-En résumé, ils passent leur journée à
boire et à chanter.
J'en connais qui ont attrapé une bien mauvaise
réputation pour moins que ça.
-Oui enfin plus chanter que boire, quand même.
Et c'est pour le salut.
Des gens.
Cluny rend aussi importante la nécrologie:
quand un membre meurt, on l'écrit dans le
nécrologe pour lui adresser des prières
et on donne son repas à un pauvre pendant
8 jours après le décès puis à chaque jour
anniversaire de sa mort mais comme le temps
passe et les moines ne sont pas éternels
on est bien obligé de diminuer cette générosité
au bout d'un moment sinon y'a plus rien à
manger.
Et puis enfin, les moines des abbayes clunisiennes
sont des lettrés et ont des ateliers de copistes
fort réputés qui enrichissent la bibliothèque
de Cluny et celles à qui ils vendent leurs
manuscrits.
Par contre niveau école et activité intellectuelle,
c'est pas encore les meilleurs.
D'autres monastères décident à leur tour
de fonder leur groupe de leur côté.
C'est le cas des Chartreux, qui ne sont pas
des chats gris soyeux mais une communauté
de moines fondée par Bruno.
Comme les premiers moines il commence par
se retirer du monde avec quelques copains
à la fin du XIe siècle, puis fonde un monastère
avec une règle très austère: son but
est de retrouver la recherche de solitude
des moines, et pour cela ils vivent dans des
petites maisons autour du cloître, pratiquent
le vœu de silence quasi perpétuel et ne
sortent pas du monastère.
En 1300 il y a 300 chartreuses, qu'on appelle
aussi ermitages, ce qui montrent bien leur
volonté de vivre reclus.
C'est le seul ordre qui n'a subi aucune réforme
depuis le MA, les moines y vivent toujours
dans le silence, assurent leurs revenus par
la vente de liqueur et l'ermitage principal
est même interdit de survol pour les protéger
de tout bruit extérieur.
-Peut-être qu'ils savent pas qu'ils vivent
au XXIe siècle alors.
Peut-être qu'ils croient que c'est dangereux
de sortir de leur monastère.
Peut-être que c'est le plot twist d'un film
ça déjà, non?
-Chut.
Il existe d'autres congrégations, qui comme
pour les chartreux commencent souvent par
un moine, un endroit désert, de l'inspiration.
Au XIe siècle le cénobitisme revient à
la mode, on veut revenir aux sources, rester
pauvres, manger et s'habiller simplement,
de petits groupes se retirent sur des terres
données par un seigneur et certains de ces
mouvements se transforment en ordres monastiques.
C'est ainsi qu'apparaît l'ordre cistercien,
souvent vu comme le grand concurrent de Cluny.
A la base, Robert de Molesme est un abbé
qui décide de quitter son monastère pour
fonder une communauté d'ermites à la fin
du XIe siècle.
En 1098 il fonde une abbaye à Cîteaux et
il n'en repartira pas.
De Cîteaux.
L'abbaye reste isolée et austère, les moines
vivent dans des huttes, meurent et se renouvellent
très peu...
Jusqu'au successeur de Robert, Bernard de
Clairvaux qui rentre à Cîteaux avec trente
parents et amis, des femmes qui fondent un
monastère féminin à côté...
A partir de là c'est la start up nation.
Dès 1115 il existe quatre nouveaux monastères,
et 700 en 1300.
Les statuts de l'ordre sont appelés la «Charte
de charité» et sont très sévères contre
toutes les formes de richesse.
Les idées principales sont la revalorisation
du travail manuel, qui passe par le refus
des dîmes: les moines exploitent eux-même
leurs terres via les frères convers, qui
sont des moines mais pas complètement.
-Ils appliquent aussi la réduction de la
durée des offices qui duraient trois plombes
dans les monastères clunisiens, et mettent
en places des chapitres généraux, des grandes
réunions annuelles pour parler des problèmes.
Le succès de l'ordre cistercien réside aussi
dans le rôle de Bernard: il devient rapidement
connu pour s'en prendre à Cluny, puisqu'il
considère que seul une vie humble peut mener
à la perfection des hommes alors que Cluny
se veut plus progressiste.
Cluny répond à Bernard, ça part en bataille
des mots, bref...
Bernard pense aussi que les moines doivent
chercher à transmettre la foi mais pas à
la comprendre ni l'interpréter, il participe
à ce titre au procès d'Abélard, un intellectuel
qui au contraire pensait qu'il fallait analyser
la Bible, sacrilège.
-Pour montrer son opposition à Cluny, dont
les moines portaient un habit noire, il décide
que les cisterciens s'habilleront en blanc.
Et toc!
-Il parcourt l'Europe pour fonder des monastères,
conseille même des princes et le pape, mais
perd un peu en popularité lorsqu'il prêche
la IIe croisade à la demande du pape et qu'elle
échoue monumentalement.
Mais ça, Confession d'Histoire en a déjà
très bien parlé.
Avec toutes ces nouvelles organisations, une
réflexion se développe dans la société
sur qu'est-ce qu'être un moine, finalement?
Le schéma traditionnel de la société médiévale
veut qu'il existe trois ordres: les moines,
ceux qui prient...
-Oratores.
-Les nobles qui font la guerre..
-Bellatores
-Et les pécores qui labourent les champs.
-Laboratores.
-Ah tu sais dire travail maintenant!
-Pff.
-L'abbé Abbon de Fleury émet une autre théorie
qui donne différents bons points aux gens
une fois qu'ils seront morts: les moines
arriveraient ainsi dans l'au-delà avec 100
points alors que les clercs en auront 60 et
les laïcs seulement 30.
Cela explique pourquoi certains abbés comme
Bernard de Clairvaux, ou l'abbé Suger sont
vus comme des stars sages et avisées.
De toute façon devenir moine devrait être
l'objectif ultime de tout individu, les femmes
sont sournoises sauf si elles sont religieuses
ou saintes et quiconque s'attaquerait à un
monastère recevrait malheur et châtiment.
-Oui enfin on pensait pas tous comme ça hein.
-Et en plus, inciter les gens à devenir moines
permet de freiner la croissance démographique
et de préserver les ressources.
Pour entrer au monastère il était possible
de se «donner» avec ses biens et ses
terres en échange de protection et de prières.
Cela donne les fameux frères convers dont
on a parlé un peu plus tôt, ils entrent
au monastère à l'âge adulte et n'ont pas
un statut de moine à part entière, on leur
file souvent les travaux manuels.
Les autres membres du monastères sont des
enfants donnés au monastère pour y recevoir
une bonne éducation, les oblats.
Les nobles continuent aussi de faire des dons
réguliers pour bien s'assurer des prières
à leur nom.
Devenir moine n'est pas forcément une vocation:
quand Bernard de Clairvaux entre au monastère
avec toute sa famille il doit bien les convaincre,
notamment sa sœur et le mari de celle-ci
parce que forcément ça modifie quelque peu
leurs relations.
Les enfants de nobles ou de chevaliers qui
sont envoyés au monastère n'ont pas forcément
eu leur mot à dire et tout ça peut avoir
des conséquences psychologiques pour eux.
Otloh de Saint-Emmeran, par exemple, est un
moine bénédictin du XIe siècle qui traverse
une longue crise existentielle où il doute
même de l'existence de Dieu, pense que sa
vie n'a aucun sens...
Tout ça parce qu'il vit depuis son enfance
entre les quatre murs de son abbaye.
Dans la plupart des cas, au MA, on ne permet
pas aux moines de penser par eux-même, ils
sont incités à se consacrer aux textes religieux
sans se poser de questions et les ouvrages
antiques présents dans les monastères posent
problème à certains abbés qui les accusent
d'être cause de décadence.
Chez les cisterciens, des moines qui auraient
composé des vers, crime horrible, doivent
être transférés dans une autre abbaye et
ne peuvent pas revenir dans leur monastère
d'origine.
Comme je l'ai déjà dit dans la première
partie, au XIe siècle les ermites reviennent
à la mode au point de devenir un groupe social
à part.
Enfin, un groupe.
Vous m'avez comprise.
Il peut s'agir de moines qui décident de
vivre encore plus reclus, d'anciens soldats,
de personnes ressentant le besoin de faire
pénitence...
On les reconnaît alors à leur barbe et à
la mélote qu'ils portent, une tunique de
laine non teinte ou de peau.
Leurs activités sont lire, prier, conseiller
ceux qui viennent les voir ou prêcher s'ils
ont beaucoup de visiteurs.
Le peuple vénère ces hommes au point de
construire des chapelles sur le lieu où un
ermite a vécu.
-Parce qu'être ermite n'est pas définitif.
Si le gars en a marre ou a terminé sa pénitence,
il coupe sa barbe, enlève sa mélote et retrouve
le monde.
-La popularité des ermites permet à deux
personnages, en particulier, de donner naissance
parfois malgré eux à des ordres mendiants.
-Et c'est qui ces personnages?
-TOP je nais en Espagne en 1170, parcourant
le Languedoc pour prêcher contre le catharisme
je m'installe finalement à Toulouse en 1215
et y fonde l'ordre des frères prêcheurs
avec l'autorisation du pape, plus connu sous
le nom d'ordre dominicain, je suis, je suis...
-Dominique.
-Ah, je l'avais presque!
-Saint Dominique accorde de l'importance à
deux choses: les études, et la prédication.
La prédication se fait dans le but de répandre
la foi et la morale et se fait en imitant
la vie des apôtres, c'est à dire en pratiquant
l'itinérance et la mendicité.
Les frères, qui sont tous égaux, voient
alors les couvents dominicains comme des lieux
de formation et de ressourcement mais pas
des résidences.
Les couvents prennent le nom de studia, les
novices peuvent y faire leurs études théologiques.
Au cours du XIIIe siècle ils posent les bases
des études secondaires en les organisant
et en ouvrant des studia dans de nombreuses
villes qui deviennent par la suite universitaires:
Paris, Oxford, Montpellier, ou Barcelone ont
chacune au moins un studium dominicain qui
attire des étudiants de toute l'Europe.
Mais l'histoire des universités est une autre
histoire, qu'on abordera peut-être un jour
plus en détail.
L'ordre dominicain se caractérise aussi par
le refus de la propriété.
Seuls la possession du couvent, sa chapelle,
son jardin, et quelques livres pour les moines
sont tolérés mais ils restent modestes,
les moines sont incités à mendier leur nourriture
et leur logement.
Une branche féminine apparaît rapidement,
qui se rapproche un peu plus des monastères
«classiques» mais se consacre entre
autres à aider des prostituées à se convertir
en moniales.
-Et l'autre ordre?
-Je suis né en Italie en 1182, issu d'une
famille bourgeoise je décide de me faire
ermite à l'âge de 25 ans et suis déshérité
par mon père.
Aidant les pauvres et les lépreux, restaurant
des chapelles, je rassemble rapidement autour
de moi un groupe de compagnons et décide
de leur donner une règle de vie basée sur
la pauvreté et la prédication, mon ordre
s'appelle Frères de la pénitence, frères
mineurs ou encore frères franciscains, je
suis, je suis...
-FRANCIS!
-François.
-C'est pas juste.
-Saint François d'Assise encourage encore
plus que les franciscains ses frères à mener
une vie simple.
Il n'exige d'eux aucune formation ni qualité
intellectuelle, rejette les études, et leur
fait revêtir la tenue traditionnelle des
pauvres d'Italie: une robe brune à capuchon
et une corde en guise de ceinture.
Et il aimait les canards, apparemment.
Jusque 1229, les franciscain envoyés en France
et en Allemagne sont considérés comme des
hérétiques.
On retrouve ce questionnement sur la place
des franciscains parmi les autres ordres religieux
dans le livre et film Le Nom de la Rose, où
Guillaume de Baskerville et son disciple,
des franciscains, sont envoyés dans une abbaye
bénédictine pour enquêter sur une mort
suspecte.
On observe déjà là les différences entre
leurs deux ordres jusqu'à ce qu'un inquisiteur,
ancien dominicain, débarque et se mette à
parler d'hérésie.
En effet beaucoup s'inspirent de saint François
pour adopter le mode de vie franciscain tout
en restant laïcs et mariés.
Un ordre féminin, les clarisses, apparaît
aussi rapidement et fait vœu de clôture
perpétuelle.
On imagine mal des femmes prêcher et parcourir
les routes au XIIIe siècle malheureusement.
A la fin du XIIIe siècle l'ordre est organisé,
composé de maisons, hiérarchisé...
Et ça crée un conflit interne sur la place
de la pauvreté dans l'ordre, le nouveau dirigeant
de l'ordre étant accusé de trahir la volonté
de saint François.
L'activité intellectuelle de l'ordre progresse
malgré les divisions, et Jean de Parme, l'un
des dirigeants suivants, rédige même une
nouvelle Vie de saint François qui arrange
ses affaires.
Ce dernier, dépassé par l'ampleur que prenait
son mouvement et n'appréciant pas l'organisation
qui se mettait en place, s'était depuis longtemps
retiré des affaires.
Il consacre la fin de sa vie à la méditation
et aurait bénéficié de quelques miracles
qui lui valent d'être canonisé deux ans
après sa mort.
Et il aimait toujours les oiseaux.
-Ah je comprenais pas aussi pourquoi ils avaient
tous «Saint» comme prénom à chaque
fois.
C'était pas leur prénom.
-D'autres ordres mendiants moins répandus
apparaissent comme les carmélites, les augustins,
les clarisses...
Leur succès inquiète le clergé des villes,
qui les voient comme des concurrents, mais
ils sont rapidement soutenus par les papes
qui récupèrent ces mouvements comme des
outils de prédication.
Malgré la popularité de ces ordres en rupture
avec tout ce qui se faisait en matière de
moines jusque là, les clunisiens et cisterciens
continuent leur expansion:
On a donc au XIIIe siècle une diversité
religieuse plus forte que jamais, juste avant
que les moines commencent à perdre leur influence.
Aux XIIe et XIIIe siècles les monastères
étaient au sommet de leur gloire, aussi bien
au niveau spirituel, politique, économique...
Mais à partir de cette époque leur rôle
commence à être réduit au religieux et
au social uniquement, jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Mais c'est pas fini! Avant de dire au-revoir
à nos chers monastères, voyons un peu plus
en détail ce qui s'y passe, de manière générale,
indépendamment des périodes ou des ordres
religieux.
Généralement, les monastères s'installent
dans des sites agréables comme des vallées,
déjà exploitées par l'homme.
Ils ne s'établissent en forêt que s'ils
ont l'intention de la défricher, l'idée
n'est pas de vivre isolé de tous contrairement
aux ermites puisqu'ils sont souvent à plus
ou moins long terme à la tête d'une seigneurie,
un petit bourg peut se former autour d'eux.
-Ça dépend des ordres: les chartreux s'installent
tout près des villes, mais les cisterciens
se mettent plus à l'écart et renomment toujours
le lieu où ils construisent leur abbaye.
-Et puis, détail pratique, ils s'arrangent
pour avoir de l'eau pas loin.
-Aux Ve et VIe siècles les moines dormaient
encore dans des cellules isolées, qui se
transforment ensuite en dortoirs.
-C'est aussi à cette époque qu'apparaît
le cloître.
Moins les moines sortent, plus il leur faut
de la place à l'intérieur.
Vers 820 est rédigé le plan de Saint Gall,
un monastère qui se veut un modèle pour
les créations ultérieures.
On y trouve la répartition de chaque bâtiment,
avec le scriptorium, la salle de réunions,
une galerie, le dortoir au deuxième niveau,
le réfectoire côté Sud...
Il reprend en gros le schéma d'une villa
romaine.
-AH! Des hommes de goût.
-Autour des abbayes peuvent exister des prieurés,
des constructions plus petites qui comptent
4 à 20 moines et qui ont rattachées à une
abbaye pour s'isoler, s'il s'agit de moines
qui choisissent de vivre encore plus en ermites,
ou pour mieux contrôler les terres de l'abbaye.
Ils ont aussi une fonction d'hospitalité
et sont plus proches des gens, leur église
sert souvent à la paroisse.
On trouve aussi parfois sous la juridiction
d'une abbaye des granges confiées à des
moines ou des hôpitaux qui accueillent les
pèlerins et les voyageurs pauvres.
J'ai déjà parlé un peu des différentes
personnes qui peuplent un monastère: on
trouve des oblats, les enfants donnés au
monastère par leurs parents;
-Les convers, qui sont souvent illettrés
et n'ont pas tous les droits des moines mais
s'occupent de l'administration des terres
et des travaux manuels;
-Quelques laïcs, aussi, qui décident de
venir vivre comme des moines, sans être moines.
-On les appelle ad succurendum.
Ce sont souvent des personnes âgées qui
rejoignent les monastères à la fin de leur
vie pour s'assurer une bonne vie après la
mort.
-Ça me paraît un peu facile.
-Généralement ils prononcent ce vœu juste
avant de mourir, mais s'ils survivent ils
doivent maintenir leur promesse, dommaaage....
-Et puis il y a les «familiers», les
serviteurs, les cuisiniers...
Des laïcs qui peuvent être payés ou bénévoles.
-Rappelons aussi qu'il existe beaucoup d'aides
dans les monastères féminins, puisque les
femmes ne peuvent pas effectuer autant de
tâches religieuses ou administratives que
les hommes.
Et puis y'a les moines, quand même.
Parmi eux on trouve l'abbé et tout un tas
d'officiers monastiques qui sont là pour
l'aider: le prieur, qui est un peu son bras
droit, le camérier qui s'occupe des revenus
et des objets précieux, l'hôtelier qui comme
son nom l'indique accueille les hôtes...
-L'aumônier qui fait l'aumône aux pauvres,
le cellérier qui veille à l'approvisionnement...
-Le grainetier.
Il s'occupe du grain.
Et l'infirmier.
Je vous fait un dessin?
-Le vinnetier est chargé du vin, ce qui est
un peu la tâche la plus importante, avec
le réfectorier, qui s'occupe du réfectoire.
-Évidemment.
On trouve aussi l'armarius qui gère la bibliothèque
et ses petits amis les copistes, mais on en
reparlera très bientôt, suspens suspens.
Et enfin le chantre, qui s'occupe du déroulement
de la liturgie.
Généralement on considère que pour gérer
une abbaye il faut un abbé et 12 moines,
comme Jésus et ses douze apôtres, mais on
trouve des abbayes qui explosent ces chiffres
comme Cluny qui compte 300 à 400 moines.
Les tâches des moines sont diverses.
Ils assurent le service liturgique quotidien,
le dimanche, pour les fêtes, et sont souvent
aussi chargés du service paroissial dans
leur seigneurie.
Sinon, ce sont eux qui installent des curés
dans les paroisses, en leur fournissant un
salaire et tout ce qu'il faut pour vivre.
-Ils s'occupent aussi des prières pour les
défunts, à partir du nécrologe qui s'étoffe
de plus en plus au fil des années.
-Ils ont aussi un rôle d'éducation et de
transmission de la culture, via la formation
qu'ils délivrent à quelques enfants placés
au monastère le temps de leurs études uniquement
et grâce aux bibliothèques et scriptoria
qu'ils possèdent: les moines copistes recopient
des manuscrits religieux ou progressivement
des ouvrages antiques, un travail très long
puisqu'un manuscrit complet peut prendre quelques
mois à quelques années pour être achevé.
Mais on en reparlera très bientôt parce
qu'il paraît que la prochaine vidéo de cette
chaîne sera une collaboration sur l'histoire
des bibliothèques.
-Mais on en fait tout le temps, des collabs!
-Enfin, sans vous quoi.
Avec une autre chaîne.
Vous êtes pas invitées.
-PARDON?!
-Bref.
Il peut arriver que les monastères possèdent
des reliques, ce qui est vachement la classe
en terme de prestige.
Ils leur rendent alors un culte et elles peuvent
s'avérer fort pratiques en cas de problèmes.
En 1066, l'abbaye de Valenciennes est détruite
dans un incendie.
Pour financer la reconstruction les moines
font alors une grande tournée avec les reliques
de saint Amand et récoltent de l'argent partout
où ils passent.
En gros la journée d'un moine se divise toujours
entre la prière tous ensemble, la lecture
de la Bible et le travail manuel ou intellectuel,
dans des proportions qui varient selon les
ordres.
La plupart du temps tout cela se fait dans
le silence, sauf la messe forcément.
On distingue alors le silence simple, où
les moines parlent à voix basse, et le grand
silence.
Pour communiquer les moines utilisent des
tablettes ou encore un langage des signes
très élaboré et différent selon les ordres
religieux.
Et enfin, ils gèrent leur exploitation et
en tirent un revenu en vendant de la laine
par exemple.
C'est probablement de cette activité que
nous viennent toutes nos belles images d'alcools
et de fromages produits par des moines, mais
c'est loin d'être leur activité principale
au MA.
Ils en produisent, bien sûr, et en vendent,
mais les produits actuels n'ont pas grand
chose à voir avec leurs ancêtres.
La liqueur produite par les moines chartreux
n'est mise en vente qu'au XVIIIe siècle,
par exemple.
Les moines sont à l'origine de l'invention
de certains types de fromages, puisqu'ils
en produisaient pour eux, mais ils n'ont aucun
rapport avec le chaussée aux moines.
Les fromages ou bières effectivement produites
par des moines, comme le Mont des Cats ou
la Chimay, le sont en grande partie par des
moines trappistes.
-Placement de produiiit.
-Même pas.
Les trappistes sont un ordre issu des cisterciens
et apparu au XIXe siècle, on est loin du
MA.
Ils commencent à commercialiser leurs bières
au XXe siècle, dans un souci de money, pour
l'entretien de leur monastère, et les bières
trappistes ne doivent pas être confondues
avec les bières d'abbayes qui comme leur
nom l'indique ne sont pas brassées en abbaye.
Mais elles gardent un lien avec des abbayes
existantes ou ayant existé.
Et enfin il y a des tas de bières qui portent
le nom «abbaye» mais n'ont rien à voir
avec la choucroute.
-Tu veux dire la bière?
-Ne gâche pas mes répliques s'il te plaît.
En France, puisque les bières d'abbaye sont
plutôt un truc de belges, on trouve UNE bière
d'abbaye produite par des moines, la Saint-Wandrille,
qui est créée en 2016.
Pour le côté médiéval on repassera donc,
je vous remercie de m'avoir encore une fois
laissé péter toutes vos idées reçues sur
le sujet, c'est tout pour moi.
-Tu comptes vraiment terminer ta vidéo ainsi?
Prends une année sabbatique, pendant que
tu y es!
-Je te demande pardon?
-Ce n'est pas pour te jeter la pierre, mais
je doute que tes abonnés soient au septième
ciel avec une telle conclusion.
-Oooh...
Je vois, mais tu vas arrêter tout de suite
tes jérémiades, je fais des vidéos, pas
des miracles, j'ai déjà déplacé des montagnes
pour la préparer pendant que tu restais là
à être une plaie...
-Ne me fais pas croire que tu as vécu un
calvaire pour la préparer, je ne crois que
ce que je vois et tu n'as pas parole d'évangile.
Tu me dois déjà une fière chandelle de
rester ici alors que tous les chemins mènent
à Rome.
-Eh ben retournes-y, à ta terre promise,
tu crois que t'es en odeur de sainteté ici?
Y'a encore quelques mois je te connaissais
ni d'Eve, ni d'Adam, et tu dois ton salut
qu'à ma générosité!
-Je me lave les mains de tes problèmes, je
ne serai pas ton bouc émissaire et si tu
crois que je vais te porter au pinacle...
-Ha-ha, j'en lève les bras au ciel tellement
tu... tu l'emporteras pas au Paradis...
-Oh, vanité des vanités, à quel saint me
vouer...
-Et voilà, c'est encore le capharnaüm, ça
va être la croix et la bannière pour calmer
la p'tite...
-LA VACHE, j'bite pas un mot de ce que vous
dites.
*Regards consternés de la Prof et Lucretia
-C'est moi la p'tite?
-C'était plutôt amusant.
-Oui.
Adieu!